we do have Darius with us Darius we were
looking at your game and it felt so
dangerous all of his pieces were
pointing at your king you had the Knight
on F6 you had that crucial Bishop on f8
what was your assessment at that point
were are you worried that there might be
some sacrifices coming your
way I wasn't really worried honestly I
wasn't really worried I saw that Bishop
on the8 on F6 I'm very solid on the king
side so I didn't really really feel like
there is any any danger there and uh I
was honestly sort of expecting this
queen C1 Bishop A3 because it's hard for
him also to kind of like make a move
especially that we are like move number
25 50 more moves he had some time
Advantage but uh we in the end was equal
on time so I didn't really feel any
danger there so so if he doesn't do
something what was your uh plan let's
say he go something like King to H2 in
this position what what was your
plan uh I mean I I thought we both have
to just sort of sit in way like I I was
thinking of Queen B8 or queen A8 ideas
or something maybe I could try Rook some
some someday of course Rook A2 or
something of course I have to be careful
we should be free tempo of course but uh
yeah like I it's kind of like a waiting
game for both of us in this at this
point so I wasn't really sure like you
know what we are both doing in this
position so I thought like draw like by
repetition in this way is the most
logical out and I think uh you both were
right in that regard because after King
H2 your idea of Queen to A8 does seem to
be giving you some play in the position
as well via the A and B file so you have
a lot of ways to improve your1 for black
but I really don't believe that it's
it's very close to equality very
balanced but you get some play right you
have ideas you have moves to improve
your
position yeah I mean I I thought it was
close to equal well anyway so I mean
draw is a normal result especially with
black pieces so yeah it is what it is
and that's what we uh thought so as well
Kina you have a question for darus yeah
darus we see a number of blenders in
this round so I'm curious how tired did
you feel coming into this round and was
the draw also like a kind of strategic
result not to blunder today and wait for
the rest rest
day uh yeah I mean pretty I'm pretty I'm
pretty sure that everyone is already a
little bit tired so probably everyone's
looking forward to the rest day uh
personally um I didn't look at it like
that even though probably I'm like tired
like everyone else uh everyone has eight
games sort of under our backs so uh yeah
but I mean I just to try to to I one
game at a time and uh you know
um try to be solid play play good moves
and um see how it goes and uh um yeah
and no I knew that after the rest I have
two whites and one black so I mean the G
goes on can I say thank you so yeah
making a draw with black and expecting
those two whites that's nice yeah good
luck uh in the remaining rounds D guys
breaking news breaking news